perhaps the most resilient building in  the world can be found in the yangtze  river in china where it has stood for  the past 700 years  [Music]  guanying pavilion also known as the  goddess of mercy pavilion is a temple  located in ezu city in china's hubei  province  its origins date back to the yuan  dynasty and is the only temple built on  the nearly 4 000 mile long yang sea  river  the temple sits on a large reef rock in  the river during the rainy season the  temple's foundation is submerged in  water and the building looks as if it's  floating  today the pavilion isn't open to the  public however that doesn't stop  adventurous swimmers from exploring the  structure  while floods and heavy rainstorms have  washed away trees and more modern  structures guanying pavilion still  stands strong it's a testament to the  architectural engineering of its  ancestors  [Applause]  [Music]